Speaker 1: Some of you may be familiar with the
right wing musical artist who goes by the name
Kid Rock. Kid Rock has developed a friendship of
some kind with the former President Donald Trump,
including playing golf, etc.. He was recently
interviewed by Tucker Carlson. The interviews
bizarre Tucker Carlson's appearance and demeanor
during the interview are extremely strange,
but the big revelation from the interview is Kid
Rock claims that Donald Trump would ask him about
foreign policy advice and about tweets that he
was imminently going to send out. Related to
relationships with foreign countries and the like,
now we're going to look at Kid Rock explaining
this to Tucker Carlson, but I think what one
important thing to keep in mind is, I doubt.
That Kid Rock was the least qualified person to
give Donald Trump advice on policy like this. It's
outrageous that Kid Rock was put in that position.
But there were probably equally unqualified
people, and at least Kid Rock seems to recognize
how absurd it was for him to be pulled into this
stuff. So let's jump into the interview here.
Speaker 2: I think Trump let me. Trump, though,
at the White House with Sarah Palin's White House
and now Sarah Palin asked them to was friendly
with her and early right when he got elected, he
invited her to dinners and bring some interesting
people right. So she said she called me and and
Ted Ted Nugent and was like, Hell, yeah. And if
they ran, it would become a buddies and spent a
lot of time on the golf course now. And really,
where get phone calls from staffers? It's kind of
mind blowing. What's he like to play golf with?
Awesome. So much fun. Really? Why? He just knows
how to have fun. Doesn't take it too seriously.
Yeah. You know he's engaging. It's
just you just cut it up. Just open
with politics. Matt was there with him one
day when he handed the caliphate right.
Speaker 1: He wanted that in the one
day when the the entire caliphate
ended. You guys remember that day, write
Speaker 2: out a tweet, and it was like,
I don't like to speak out of school. I hope I'm
not, but that's not like you like, tell my me.
The tweet was it. I'm paraphrasing, but it's like,
you know, if you ever join the cafe, you know and
try to do this, you're going to be dead. He goes,
What do you think at all? Awesome. Right? Yeah.
Tweet that out. Say, I can't add anything better
than that. But then it comes out. It's very it's
reword it in more political and like it, a little
politically correct. It might just be a know.
We're looking at maps. I'm like, you know, I'm
like, Am I supposed to be like, you know, dope?
Speaker 1: Very, very trustworthy. That Trump
with classified and sensitive information, as we
all know. Remember Hillary's emails and all that.
Speaker 2: I make dirty records sometimes, but I
do it here. You know, I think you'd have a hand.
We think we should do about North Korea. I'm like,
what? I don't think I'm qualified to answer this.
Speaker 1: At least Kid Rock knew he wasn't
qualified, at least at least. And Tucker
just finds it hilarious. And it's funny how
if any of these types of folks had like an inside
line to Joe Biden and the Oval Office and were
even on the periphery of anything substantive,
Tucker wouldn't be laughing the way he's laughing.
He'd be calling for an impeachment.
Speaker 2:
How does it happen? So you're you're still
playing golf with them down in Florida? Yeah,
yeah. How's he seem? What's that? How's he
seem? He seems great. He seems great. You know,
after the election, it was, you know, little,
you know, a little different there. And but I
still same guy. He sits down. He just cuts it up.
Just don't cut it up. It's just how sharp he is is
incredible. And you can see now if you watch a Joe
Biden interview and you watch a Trump interview,
it just like there's there's no comparison.
Speaker 1: Now that is true. I mean,
you guys remember all of the
incredibly astute and articulate and
just the clarity with which Trump would speak.
Speaker 2: And God bless the United States.
Take a look at the origins of the
investigation. The noise causes cancer.
Speaker 1: Right? You guys you you remember
all of that stuff and just always just so
clear and concise, and it all made sense. So
this is pretty dangerous. And it also exposes
the double standard, of course, that, like I said,
if I mean, listen, during the presidency, Jared
and Ivana everywhere, Ivanka sitting in for Rex
Tillerson once at a meeting at least once that we
know about. If you know Hunter Biden, if Hillary
Clinton had been president and and her daughter
had been in any way involved in the presidency,
these very people would be going bananas,
arguing This is criminal and it's all going to.
And meanwhile, you know, Kid Rock, Ivanka, Jared
Kushner, what? They just don't care. And it's yet
another one of these incredible double standards.